sie wählen werden deshalb wollen tina
hassel und ich in dieser runde einige
der wichtigen themen ausloten die bisher
wenig oder gar nicht behandelt wurden
neben corona und dem zustand unserer
gesellschaft geht es auch um
deutschlands künftige rolle in der welt
ja denn ganz gleich wer diese wahl
hinterher gewinnen wird sie wird eine
zeitenwende sein und deshalb haben sie
in den kommenden 90 minuten die
möglichkeit noch einmal alle argumente
aller parteichefs spitzen kandidaten und
kandidatinnen sehr genau zu prüfen und
natürlich auch zu beobachten wie die
runde miteinander umgeht wo eventueller
wissen gemacht werden oder ganz klare
grenzen gesetzt werden auf jeden fall
herzlich willkommen zur schlussrunde in
ard und zdf und hier sind unsere gäste
in strengt alphabetischer reihenfolge
guten haben sondern in hamburg
spitzenkandidatin kanzlerkandidatin der
grün sie kommen armin laschet
kanzlerkandidat der union und wir kommen
christian lindner spitzenkandidaten und
wir begrüßen natürlich auch olaf scholz
den kanzlerkandidaten der spd
wir begrüßen den csu chef markus söder
die spitzenkandidaten der afg alice
weide und für die linke deren
spitzenkandidaten janine wissler und wir
beginnen mit einem aktuellen thema das
im moment die republik erschüttert und
viele fassungslos macht ein masken
verweigerer erschießt einen jungen
kassierer in einer tankstelle weil der
ihn auf die krone regeln hingewiesen
hatte im netz wird der täter von vielen
dafür sogar zynisch gefeiert die
polizeigewerkschaft gdp spricht schon
davon dass sich die szene der korona
leutner immer weiter radikalisiert herr
laschet experten haben ja schon lange
gewarnt dass es nur noch eine frage der
zeit ist wann aus hasserfüllten
botschaften irgendwann auch eine tat
folgt haben sie haben wir alle diese
szene zu lange unterschätzt
also der anschlag in idar oberstein ist
natürlich schrecklich man kann sich das
kaum vorstellen ein 20 jähriger jobbt da
student tut nichts anders als auch die
regeln hinzuweisen und dann wird der
kaltblütig erschossen und meine sorge
bei all diesen taten ist die
radikalisierung beginnt im netz immer
aggressiver immer lauter wir haben es
bei den rechtsradikalen erlebt beim
stimmungsmachern gegen walter lübke und
irgendwann ist einer da unvollendet
diese tat das müssen wir dringend diesem
hass und entgegenstellen und ihn schon
im ansatz ersticken
aber herr laschet er die unionsfraktion
hat wichtige vorhaben verhindert das
sogenannte wehrhafte demokratie gesetzt
auch ein gesetz zur besseren überprüfung
von waffenbesitzern das hat jetzt der
innenminister seehofer selber kritisiert
also dieser hass
lässt sich auch nicht durch eine
wehrhafte demokratie gesetz beseitigen
wir brauchen eine wehrhafte demokratie
wir brauchen auch regeln wie man
rassismus fremdenfeindlichkeit
gewalt von allen seiten wie man die
bekämpft aber
die gesellschaftliche sorge die sich mit
diesem anschlag verbindet dass die
tonlage immer rauer wird und immer
aggressiver wird das ist etwas was wir
bekämpfen müssen und vor allem muss
jeder wissen der das macht er wirkt hier
auch auf die härte des rechtsstaats
treffen müssen wir dürfen es nicht
dulden in nordrhein westfalen haben wir
beispielsweise die praxis dass wir nicht
nur löschen im netz sondern auch die die
verletzten direkt strafrechtlich
verfolgen und ich glaube das ist
erforderlich
auch das internet ist kein rechtsfreier
raum herr scholz die stichwort wehrhafte
demokratie
die spd zeigt sich hier beim thema
online-durchsuchung bisher zurückhaltend
bis gespalten ihre justizministerin
wollte sie die parteichefin hat das
ganze gestoppt wie würde sich ein
kanzler scholz entscheiden wir haben
hier eine ganze reihe von gesetzen auf
den weg gebracht und auch beschlossen
die genau das möglich machen dass man
überprüft was alles für aktivitäten
stattfindet dass man dass man abhören
kann wo es nicht am telefon ist dann
eben gleichzeitig im netz das sind die
maßnahmen die wir möglich gemacht haben
und ich glaube dass ich so und ich
glaube dass wir auf alle fälle auch im
netz den hass bekämpfen müssen und
deshalb müssen wir auch verfolgen können
was da stattfindet und was für
kommunikationswege da sind mit den neuen
gesetzen ist das möglich mit dem dass
wir als regierung auf den weg gebracht
haben das aber leider gescheitert
deswegen am streit über andere fragen
muss man ehrlicherweise sagen mit dem
bundesrat wir das auch noch besser
möglich gewesen aber das sollten wir in
der nächsten legislaturperiode gleich
wieder versuchen das heißt sie sagen
selber es war nicht nur ausreichend nein
es sind ja mehrere gesetze für mehrere
sicherheitsbehörden für die meisten ist
es durchgekommen für die eine licht aber
das war etwas wo es ein streit gang und
andere fragen zwischen dem innenminister
den bundestagsfraktionen und dem
bundesrat ich selber hätte es gut
gefunden wenn das gesetz das die
bundesregierung auf den weg gebracht
auch was geworden wäre das will ich
gerne dazu sagen und will das nochmal
ergänzen wir brauchen klare maßnahmen im
netz um auch dort hasskriminalität
bekämpfen zu können wir brauchen eine
gute ausstattung von polizei und
sicherheitsbehörden damit wir alles
machen können um die täter zu
identifizieren und wir müssen auch im
gesellschaftlichen raum handeln können
deshalb finde ich wäre es gut gewesen
wenn das von der regierung entwickelte
wehrhafte demokratie gesetz auch im
bundestag beschlossen worden wäre ist ja
schon gesagt worden dass es nicht zu
stande gekommen ist weil die
unionsfraktionen da nicht mitmachen
wollte und ich finde es auch gut wenn
die idee die der innenminister die
innenminister der länder haben das wir
psychisch labile personen
überprüfen können und sagen können die
dürfen keine waffen besitzen wenn die
auf eine seite gesehen dass wir noch
warten aber herr lindner politiker in
diesen zeiten sind ja auch vorbilder
wenn jetzt der fdp bundestags
vizepräsident kubicki gerade gesagt hat
er sei während des lok downs in illegal
geöffneter kneipen gegangen und das sei
auch sein recht gewesen was ist das für
ein signal die fdp hat eine ganz klare
haltung regeln müssen beachtet werden
wir haben fraglos eine etwas andere
abwägung als die kolleginnen und
kollegen bei der verhältnismäßigkeit von
freiheits eingriffen haben uns oft eine
andere balance zwischen
gesundheitsschutz und auch der achtung
von bürgerrechten gewünscht aber das
natürlich vollkommen zu trennen von der
radikalisierung die wir gegenwärtig
beobachten
die muss man entschieden zurückweisen
und im übrigen auch unseren staat
ertüchtigen schon vor einigen jahren hat
der damalige innenminister thomas de
maizière darauf hingewiesen dass unsere
sicherheitsarchitektur in deutschland
modernisierungsbedürftig ist
insbesondere bundesamt für den
verfassungsschutz und die 16 landesämter
für den verfassungsschutz müssen besser
und koordiniert zusammenarbeiten
diesen aufruf von herrn de maizière sind
leider keine taten gefolgt ich glaube
eine nächste bundesregierung muss unsere
sicherheitsarchitektur in deutschland
modernisieren und im übrigen auch
digitalisiert oft genug ist das keine
frage von gesetzgebung sondern von
verwaltungs- zusammenarbeit aber ein
brauchten noch als parteichef zu herrn
kubicki und der äußerung also
signalwirkung illegale kneipen gegangen
und das sei sein recht gewesen ich habe
mich für die fdp gerade positioniert
haben kubicki müssen sie nach seinen
persönlichen
jetzt nicht hier eben nach seinem
persönlichen hintergrund befragen wir
sind eindeutig und übrigens die regeln
in schleswig-holstein macht ein
fdp-gesundheitsminister frau wie es dort
bei thema ertüchtigung der demokratie
die linke ist für die abschaffung des
verfassungsschutzes wer soll denn dann
nach ihrer meinung die radikalisierten
teile beispielsweise von corona leugnern
im netz kontrollieren oder im auge
behalten ja wir haben ja gewinn in der
ganzen geschichte das nsu dass der
verfassungsschutz er teilt das problem
war es war und nicht der lösung und ich
hab selber im eines
untersuchungsausschusses und hessen im
landtag mitgearbeitet habe dort fünf
jahre lang in die abgründe dieser
behörde gesehen und wir sind wild zu
sein oder hat die frau die ja wir sind
insbesondere meinung dass wir das v
männer system beenden müssen weil dort
wie da werden ja neonazis dafür bezahlt
dass die neonazis sind und wir sind der
meinung dass geheimdienste in einer
demokratie einfach nicht parlamentarisch
zu kontrollieren sind deswegen brauchen
wir eine aufklärung stelle die anders
arbeitet als mit geheimdienstlichen
mitteln also nicht mit v männern die aus
der nazi szene angeworben werden die
gelder bekommt auf deren informationen
man sich nicht verlassen kann und da
sind jeder meinung sind einfach nicht
die richtigen lehren aus der geschichte
des nsu gezogen worden weil die
parlamentarische kontrolle der
geheimdienste eher noch verschlechtert
wurde als verbessert und wir gesehen
haben dass es ein eigenleben gibt dass
geheimdienste entwickeln also umfeld des
nsu kern trios waren ja über 40 v männer
der verschiedenen
verfassungsschutzbehörden und die haben
es entweder nicht mitbekommen oder nicht
mitbekommen wollen traf sie glauben also
mit dem vorschlag das haben sie erklärt
würde es besser gehen man kann da seine
zweifel haben aber ich würde gerne frau
berg ins spiel holen unter diesen
radikalen querdenkern sind ja viele die
sich wirklich im widerstand gegen eine
selbst erfundene diktatur wählen und
deshalb auch glauben dass selbst gewalt
legitim wäre was ist denn die antwort
der grünen was ist ihr konzept wie man
mit diesen menschen umgehen sollte
schönen abend erstmal wir brauchen im
dreiklang und das bedeutet zuallererst
dass wir deutlich machen müssen
natürlich sind wir ein freies land das
ist die stärke unseres lands die
meinungsfreiheit aber da wo es in hass
und hetze wo es im bedrohung für andere
umschlägt da gibt sich nur widerspruch
sondern da greift der rechtsstaat voll
und ganz und das erste problem ist dass
es im netz nicht entsprechend
stattfindet weil ganz viele dieser
aufrufe sind dann in messenger gruppen
in chat gruppen wo eben entsprechend
nicht umgesetzt werden kann deswegen
erste wichtige maßnahme gerade auch mit
blick auf die großen plattform löschung
das hatten wir auch in diesem wahlkampf
immer wieder deutlich zu sehen dass
nicht stellen noch löscht und straff
ermittelt wird zweiter punkt ist mit
blick auf schnelle verfahren auch das
haben wir jetzt gesehen plakate auf
meine partei hängt die grünen aber es
hat auch uns alle drei getroffen das
sind im prinzip mord aufrufe gewesen wo
dann mit blick auf den rechtsstaat eben
gesagt wird naja ob das jetzt wirklich
ein aufruf ist das bedeutet auch zweiter
und das hat die große koalition nicht
umfassend an genug gegangen mit blick
auf die für gerichte wo wir eine
rechtsstaats offensive und vor allen
dingen mehr personal brauchen und der
dritte wichtige punkt und da sieht man
auch dass wir uns hier zwischen den
parteien unterscheiden bei diesem
furchtbaren
vorfall bei diesem furchtbaren attentat
jetzt aber auch vorher bei den
mordanschlägen auch bei amokläufen waren
immer wieder waffen im umlauf entweder
illegal oder auch waffen die legal
waffenschein hat nun dann trotzdem zu so
vielen morden geführt haben das heißt ja
wir brauchen dringend eine verschärfung
des waffenrechts in deutschland frau
weiter wir haben vom bundesinnenminister
gehört dass sich teile der querdenker
szene zunehmend radikalisieren ihr co
spitzenkandidat copala hat sogar zur
teilnahme an querdenker demos aufgerufen
wäre es in einem solchen moment nicht
höchste zeit sich von dieser szene klar
zu distanzieren
ich halte grundsätzlich nichts von
einer stigmatisierung einer
protestbewegung die sich im übrigen zu
großen teilen auch aus grünen spd cdu
wlan zusammensetzt das hat ja auch eine
erhebung ergeben
und dementsprechend sollten wir kritiker
von maßnahmen nicht stigmatisieren das
trägt nicht zur lösung doch die
legalisierten nein also es gilt ja
grundsätzlich
gewaltfreiheit sie können ihre meinung
artikulieren sie können vom
demonstrationsrecht gebrauch machen das
ist ja auch in unserem grundgesetz
verankern nicht war aber natürlich
völliger gewaltfreiheit aber jetzt noch
einmal zurück zu meinem punkt die
stigmatisierung von weiten teilen der
bevölkerung die korona maßnahmen auch
kritisieren und aus meiner sicht völlig
zu recht weil sie in weiten teilen
grundgesetzwidrig sind
das sollte man nicht tun und wenn wir
als politiker eben auch anfangen
geimpfte als versuchskaninchen zu
bezeichnen und ungeimpfte als sozial
schädlinge aber
haben wir ein gesellschaftliches problem
aber genau da fängt es an genau da fängt
die polarisierung in unserer
gesellschaft wieder an wenn jemand das
dürfen sind ich das machen weil wir jede
politik gegeben zum wiederkäuen leid
herr kohl das ist die verantwortung der
politik die menschen nicht zu
stigmatisieren sie nicht als sozial
schädlinge zu
bezeichnen oder als versuchskaninchen da
fängt es doch an und der staat die
regierung sollten die
grundgesetzwidrigen maßnahmen
zurücknehmen
gut sie haben jetzt nichts zu herrn
tillschneider gesagt zum beispiel aber
seinen corona diktatur äußerung aber
lassen was an der stelle sie haben ihren
punkt da gemacht und hatte sein gemacht
herr söder sie befürworten ja im team
vorsicht die 2g regel sie haben auch
jetzt gemeinsam eben mit den anderen
parteien die quarantäne ohne
lohnfortzahlung
beschlossen spalten wir sehenden auges
mit diesem zunehmenden druck auf
ungeimpfte die gesellschaft also
friedrich merz zum beispiel er sagt da
wir müssen über die masken pflicht
nachdenken weil sie gesellschaftlich
spaltet das was ist ihre position da wir
spielten nicht die gesellschaft für
beschützen sie wir haben jetzt drei
wellen sehr gut überstanden und es ist
einfach unwahr zu behaupten es handelt
sich um grundrechtswidrigen eingriff
nahezu alle maßnahmen sind von den
verfassungsgerichten der länder oder des
bundesverfassungsrichters ständig
überprüft worden und wurden mit 98%
entscheidungen immer wieder bestätigt
insofern ist auch gesagt ständige
suggestion die vermittelt wird das sei
grundgesetzwidrig einer der voba für die
grad afd gemacht wird muss denn die sie
stimuliert sie stigmatisiert liegt aber
sie stimuliert leute genau diese hinein
zu kommen es geht ja nicht um die ihnen
die unsicher sind darüber muss man reden
man muss auch angebote machen bei denen
die unsicher sind beim impfen aber ab
einer bestimmten schwelle und es sieht
die querdenker gibt es ein weltbild es
dahinter steht das in einer form
verklärt ist und zwar nicht quer denken
er wird nicht mehr gedacht da wird immer
mehr sich hinein verkrochen in eine
situation die dann am ende übrigens
nicht nur mit anti establishment
argumenten versehen wird sondern vor
allen dingen auch mit anti semitischen
mit sehr vielen rassistischen parolen
ich habe das auch bei unserem parteitag
immer fröhlich was ich auch immer
bekommen ist seit vielen jahren jetzt
ist es für alle die ihren darum besitzen
nicht so das problem wir werden
ordentlich geschützt aber es gibt so
viele viele menschen engagierte
mediziner mediziner pflegerinnen und
pfleger als journalistin journalisten
kommunalpolitikerin kommunalpolitiker
die einen druck ausgesetzt sind und
immer wieder wenn die aufforderung kommt
distanziert euch von so etwas dann hören
wir so argumente wie gerade und die
einzige chance die es gibt heißt auf die
unsicheren zugehen und sie mitnehmen auf
diesen prozess aber auch ein klares
stopp schild machen denen gegenüber die
diesen staat bedrohen einschüchtern
wollen und sorry wenn ich das auch sagen
ohne verfassungsschutz wird es da nicht
gehen denn diese leute verstehen jetzt
nicht mehr irgendwie ein eine nette
ansprache so am rande oder oder mal so
ein vertrauliches gespräch die erwarten
sich auch und die müssen spüren dass der
staat mit ganze entschlossenheit handelt
und wenn ich das jetzt so höre die einen
wollen nicht stigmatisieren die anderen
wollen den verfassungsschutz abschaffen
da braucht es eine klare linie und klare
kante gegenüber solchen kritik hat
schauen wir auf ein thema das nicht
minder wichtig ist für den sozialen
zusammenhalt das thema wohnen alle 20
minuten geht eine sozialwohnung verloren
jeden tag sind das 72 wohnungen die aus
der sozialbindung fallen die folge
bezahlbarer wohnraum nimmt dramatisch ab
herr laschet sozialwohnung waren doch
eigentlich ein deutsches erfolgskonzept
in den vergangenen 15 jahren hat sich
die zahl der sozialwohnungen aber fast
halbiert müssen wir da nicht eingestehen
wir haben versagt
brauchen mehr sozialwohnungen auf jeden
fall wir haben jetzt viele
sozialwohnungen die aus der
mietpreisbindung herausfallen und
deshalb ist es erforderlich bis zum
jahre
2025 1 5 millionen wohnungen neu zu
bauen und da müssen auch viele
sozialwohnungen bei seien aber die
entfernen ist ja nicht vom himmel der
kern ist man muss bauen man kann nicht
durch technische mittel durch künstliche
dinge wie das hier in berlin gemacht
worden ist vom rot rot grünen senat
glauben dass man das problem löst wir
müssen bauen bauen bauen das wird die
lage auf dem wohnungsmarkt entspannen
und neben dem freien wohnungsmarkt
brauchen wir mehr sozialen wurden und
über die frage was die politik da nicht
versagt ich meine das ist ja eine
erkenntnis die hätte man hier haben
können
also ich sehe dass die politik in den
letzten jahren vieles unternommen hat
das wir natürlich eine
zunehmende entwicklung haben dass viele
menschen in die großen städte sie ziehen
die städte sind zum magneten geworden
deshalb ist es aus meiner sicht auch so
wichtig das leben im ländlichen raum
auch attraktiv zu halten wenn jeder
denkt er muss in die große stadt ziehen
wo sein arbeitsplatz ist wird die
spaltung zwischen stadt und land noch
größer werden deshalb setzen wir uns
sehr dafür ein den ländlichen raum zu
stärken die bedingungen dort auch so zu
machen dass man dort leben kann das
pendeln übrigens anzuerkennen mit einer
pendlerpauschale und vielem anderen was
ermöglicht dass menschen dort auch
weiter ihrer arbeit nachgehen können und
das andere ist die realität ist dass
immer mehr menschen in städten wohnen
deshalb müssen wir dagegen stein frau
bärbel wohnungsnot in den großen städten
ist ein massives problem ich glaube da
sind bei uns alle am tisch einer meinung
die grüne spitzenkandidatin in berlin
bettina jarasch schließt enteignungen
von wohnungsunternehmen als ultima ratio
zumindest nicht aus wie sieht es bei
ihnen aus
wir haben eine der zentralsten sozialen
fragen unserer zeit seit einem jahrzehnt
jetzt nicht gelöst und zwar seit einem
jahrzehnt nicht gelöst von der großen
koalition wir erleben nicht nur hier in
berlin sondern wir leben auch in münchen
in hamburg dass menschen in großen
deutschen städten nicht mehr in ihren
vierteln bleiben können dass sie
vertrieben werden dass familien das
krankenschwester rentnerinnen und
rentner im zweifel sogar sagen ich will
die kleinere wohnung haben aber dies
seien doppelt so teuer und nicht mehr da
sein können aber das ist mit leben
beschreibung ja wer mag es aber um was
zu lösen muss man erst mal beschreiben
und ich frag mich echt auf wo die
sozialdemokratie war als man sie
eigentlich brauchte weil das die
sozialen bindung aufgelöst worden ist
das ist ja nichts was man nicht ändern
könnte sondern damit wohnraum nicht aus
der sozialen bindung will kann man das
gesetz ändern an der stelle man hätte
auch dafür sorgen können dass legen
naja jetzt zurück was man hätte tun das
gegenteil wurde getan dass für den
sozialen wohnungsbau wurden ein drittel
500.000 euro auch vom finanzminister
gekürzt den ländern gegeben hieß es war
aber eigentlich für kosten der
integration so und wenn wir jetzt sagen
das kann nicht so weitergehen wo wir
alles sagen wir sind einer meinung dann
muss man jetzt auch deutlich machen dass
wir für diese orte und das ist der
vorschlag in berlin auch von unserer
spitzenkandidatin für diese orte wo die
menschen vertrieben werden aus ihren
vierteln deutlich macht wir kommen hier
allein ein schiff das ist ihr vorschlag
und sagen mit den unterschiedlichen
wohnungsbaugenossenschaft mit den
eigentümern mit den immobilien
verwaltung wir sorgen gemeinsam dafür
dass die mieten nicht um mehr als zwei
prozent erhöht werden im rahmen des
mietpreises spiegelt und wenn dann
weiterhin nichts passiert dann muss man
auch dafür sorgen was bedeutet das auch
dass die menschen ihrer stadt bleiben
aber die haltung die wir jetzt haben von
der großen koalition nichts zu tun und
einfach weiter zu bauen dann bauen wir
im luxus-segment und der mittelschicht
und geringverdienern hilft das dank
einfach nur ganz kurz und raik nun als
ultima ratio finden sie unter den
beschriebenen umständen also richtig na
das ist ja keine erhaltungs frage
sondern es steht klar im grundgesetz was
aufgabe von staatlichkeit ist und es
auch im grund gerecht ein letztes mittel
auch sie jetzt auch starts richtung
steht nicht drin sein das mittel dass
ein letztes mittel auch am start zur
verfügung steht aber wir haben klar
gemacht als grüne in berlin und auch im
bund wir müssen alle schritte davor
gehen dh die löcher in der mietpreis
bremse die müssen jetzt endlich
geschlossen werden das bedeutet endlich
die mittel für sozialen wohnungsbau
weiter zu erhöhen und das bedeutet in
den hot spots wo menschen nicht mehr
bleiben können dafür zu sorgen dass die
mieten nicht einfach willkürlich weiter
erhöht aber es war auf jeden fall ein
jahr zu enteignen wenn ich das richtig
verstanden
haben da vorzugehen
extrem reden wenn man die schritte da
vorn gegangen aber trotzdem haben sie
das letzte haus geladen adriano ist klar
ein eigenes modell von berlin er ist vor
den verfassungsgerichten scheitern wird
alle vorschläge es ist eigentlich nach
erhaltung anders als bei ihnen dinge zu
lösen probleme zu lösen und nicht erst
mal probleme zu beschreiben und dann
sagen wir machen ihre historie gehört
das recht auf wohnen in unsere
verfassung bald darauf ein recht was
alle menschlichen oder vista ihr sie
haben im grunde die antwort schon
gegeben und hier in berlin wird ja am
sonntag auch darüber abgestimmt große
wohnungsunternehmen zu enteignen sie
sind dafür aber diese teuren
enteignungen schaffen nicht eine einzige
neue wohnung ja sie verhindern dass
bezahlbarer wohnraum immer weiter
zerstört wird und das ist ja das problem
dass bezahlbarer wohnraum vernichtet
wird und ich verstehe die aufregung auf
der anderen seite gar nicht beim thema
enteignungen also ist eine schwarz-gelbe
landesregierung nordrhein westfalen
gewesen wie zum beispiel für den
kohleabbau überhaupt kein problem hatte
zu enteignen oder für autobahnprojekte
oder enteignen sie doch auch und das
grundgesetz lässt das doch möglich also
lässt das doch zu dass im interesse des
gemeinwohls auch enteignungen
stattfinden und in berlin geht es
einfach um die frage das wäre eine
massive wohnungsnot haben und bauen
bauen bauen ist nicht die antwort weil
erstens wird in diesem jahr land ja jede
menge gebaut und jede menge bezahlt und
bezahlbarer wohnraum und wir können auch
nicht die letzte fläche versiegeln ist
auch umweltpolitisch nicht so klug wir
müssen verhindern dass immer mehr
wohnraum der bezahlbar war irgendwann
nicht mehr bezahlbar ist und all die
häuser und wohnungen die sich die
menschen in den innenstädten nicht mehr
leisten kann hier sind ja nicht auf
einmal weg durch wundersame art und
weise sondern die gibt es ja noch die
sind halt wo die mieten gestiegen und
deswegen sagen wir enteignung ist eine
sache da wird ja in berlin am wochenende
abgestimmt und das ist ja nun
volksentscheid das heißt die menschen
können ja demokratisch darüber
entscheiden und ich gehe davon aus dass
ich dann eine nächste regierung in
berlin daran auch hält aber ein anderes
wichtiges instrument der mieten decke
und den fordern wir als linke bundesweit
wir brauchen den mieten deckel und die
mieterinnen und mieter zu schützen damit
eben auch geringverdiener aber auch die
normalverdiener nicht verdrängt werden
aus den innenstädten hier müssen wir
dringend was tun und da reicht es nicht
zu sagen bauen bauen bauen sondern wir
müssen eingreifen in den bestand dass es
dringend notwendig und das sind wir den
mieterinnen und mietern schuldig
dann haben wir einfach ein problem der
mieten deckel in berlin wurde er vom
verfassungsgericht für illegal erklärt
wird es mit ihnen in welcher form auch
immer einer koalition garantiert keinen
bundesweiten mieten deckel geben
um noch mal auf die eine frage die immer
dort wurde eine klare antwort zu geben
ich bin dagegen dass wir jetzt
wohnungsunternehmen an der eignen ich
halte das nicht für den richtigen weg
das kostet sehr sehr viel geld und wir
sollten lieber neue wohnungen bauen und
ich glaube dass das auch wenn sie mir
das noch kurz gestatten die wichtigste
aufgabe ist wir haben es in deutschland
schon einmal geschafft 1973 war das
800.000 wohnung in einem jahr zu bauen
wir sind jetzt bei 300.000 wohnungen das
ist viel zu wenig wir müssen jedes jahr
und viele viele jahre lang 400.000
wohnungen bauen und darunter 100.000
sozialwohnungen wir haben das
grundgesetz geändert damit wir das als
bund weiter fördern können und dafür die
mittel bereitzustellen
und ich will gerne sagen das geht nur
wenn man sich mit allen zusammen
schließt mit der bauindustrie mit der
wohnungswirtschaft und noch die antwort
auf die frage die kommt mit der
wohnungswirtschaft mit den mieterinnen
und mietern und ihren organisationen mit
den städten und gemeinden mit den
landkreisen mit den ländern wir brauchen
ein großes bündnis für das wohnen in dem
wir das zustande bringen das ist mir
auch schon mal gelungen wenn ich das
sagen darf ich habe eine regional
umfrage hat sich gestellt die antwort
kriegen sie euch es ist mir auch schon
einmal gelungen und das zu machen ich
habe eine cdu geführte regierung in
hamburg abgelöst die den wohnungsbau
verschlafen hatte jetzt sind da
mittlerweile über 100.000 wohnungen
genehmigt über 77.000 gebaut sehr viele
sozialwohnungen und wer schon die frage
muss ja gesagt werden und um ihre frage
zu beantworten
ich glaube dass wir die regeln unseres
mietrechts die wir heute schon haben
verstärken müssen die dazu beitragen
dass der mietanstieg begrenzt wird das
ist aber eine andere regelung als die
die in berlin die dreharbeiten in
siethen decke und die regel und die ich
richtig finde ist dass wir einmal die
mietpreis bremse die wir schon haben bei
neuvermietung verlängern entfristen und
die lücken die da drin sind schließen
und dass wir zum zweiten ein moratorium
machen das dazu führt dass der
mietpreisanstieg begrenzt ist es wird
auch mit erhöhung geben aber nicht so
ein wort sollte ich jetzt statt für ein
garantiert kein mieten deckel das ist
das was ich nicht will ich will mit
moratorium und das habe ich gerade
vorgestellt
doch heute zu sagen also das hat ja ein
bisschen gebraucht ist sie da die klare
antwort gegeben haben ihre partei hat
mit ihrer nachbarin zur linken und zur
rechten in berlin exakt das beschlossen
und in berlin hat rot rot grün vor
einigen jahren
65.000 wohnungen verkauft für 400
millionen euro und kauft jetzt 15.000
zurück für über 2 milliarden euro wenn
das eine kluge wohnungsbaupolitik ist
und sie sogar noch dagegen regen dass
man baut
dann erkenne ich
erkenne ich nicht dass herr scholz mit
seinen partnerinnen bei den grünen und
bei den linken irgendetwas dazu beiträgt
dass wir in deutschland mehr wohnungen
haben und dass wir vor allem sozial
bezahlbare wohnung nahm air konzert in
berlin ihrer partei war jedenfalls das
falsche laschet aber ich bin
nämlich über wir reden jetzt hat man das
nächste thema wo wir wahrscheinlich
ebenso in dem entwurf
wir machen nicht alle also das können
wir auch noch mal wird das sie es fragen
im viele spielregeln wir werden nicht
alle immer zu allen fragen zu wort
kommen lassen aber
es ist ausgewogen wir werden auch nicht
immer eine uhr oder ein zeitkonto
einblenden aber es gibt menschen die
darauf achten und das die zeit nehmen
dass alle gleich gemäßigt dran kommen
und jetzt würden wir zu einem ähnlich
engagierten thema kommen wo wir darüber
sprechen nämlich über die finanzen denn
deutschland hat sich in der korona krise
massiv verschuldet und dazu kommt dass
wir den gesamten stadt umbauen müssen
digitalisierung klimaziele es wird also
sehr viel geld kosten und vielleicht
wenn wir das jetzt alles ein bisschen
schneller behandeln weil wir auch noch
zur außenpolitik kommen wollen und zu
anderen wichtigen themen frau bärbel
dieses gesamte grüne programm beruht
letztlich darauf dass die schulden remse
aufgeweicht wird und deutlich mehr
schulden gemacht werden können mal
abgesehen davon dass sie dafür eine
zweidrittel mehrheit bräuchten ist das
gerecht ist das generation gerecht weil
wir ansonsten unseren kindern und
unseren enkelkindern ein marodes land
hinterlassen wir leben jetzt schon dass
kinder nicht wirklich lernen konnten
weil es leider bei ihnen zu hause keinen
funktionierenden internetanschluss gab
geschweige denn in den schulen jede
sechste brücke jede sechste weiche jedes
sechste gleich in deutschland ist marode
mit blick auf den klimaschutz müssen ja
massiv dafür sorgen dass wir eine
wasserstoff-infrastruktur und den strom
leitungsausbau brauchen glauben wir
brauchen wir 50 milliarden jährlich
ansonsten bröckelt uns der ganze
wohlstand deutschlands in den nächsten
jahrzehnten dahin und deswegen ist unser
vorschlag die schuldenbremse die es
weiterhin geben wird durch eine
investitions regel zu erweitern damit
wir in unser land in die infrastruktur
in das was deutschland stark macht in
den nächsten jahren auch investieren und
unseren kindern nicht ein kaputtes land
hinter lindner das ausweichen der
schuldenbremse wäre das für sie als
künftiger möglicher künftiger
finanzminister ein ausschlusskriterium
für eine koalition ja fraglos das ist
nicht ratsam in der aktuellen situation
wir haben in deutschland ein hohes
defizit wir sind sehr stark verschuldet
in europa wir haben inzwischen sogar
inflationsrisiken die wir beobachten ich
bin in sorge dass unsere europäische
zentralbank auch gehindert sein könnte
gegen die inflation zu arbeiten wegen
der hohen verschuldung in europa deshalb
muss der weg von frau berbalk
ausgeschlossen werden aber es spricht ja
nichts dagegen investitionen
anzuschieben
insbesondere im privaten bereich frau
berbalk müssen die investitionen
erfolgen
digitalisierung und klimaschutz das sind
aufgaben der transformation auch der
privaten wirtschaft und deshalb ist der
vorschlag dass wir beginnen mit einem
super abschreibungs programm das
anlageinvestitionen der betriebe etwa
für klimafreundliche technologien
digitalisierung binnen zwei jahren
abgeschrieben werden idealerweise
kombiniert mit dem gezielten
bürokratieabbau planungs beschleunigung
und wünschenswerter weise auch der
abschaffung des solidaritätszuschlags
und gestalten sie in zweiten gedanken
warum kommt niemand auf die idee statt
die steuern zu erhöhen oder die
schuldenbremse aufzuweichen einmal zu
fragen ob es nicht innerhalb des
staatshaushaltes ausgaben gibt die wir
nicht mehr brauchen hier ist ein
vorschlag wir haben eine exzellent
wettbewerbsfähige deutsche
automobilindustrie mit großartigen
produkten auch elektroautos warum wird
das noch mit so viel geld mit milliarden
subventioniert obwohl die konzerne
milliardengewinne machen bis zu 20.000
euro für ein elektrofahrzeug selbst für
den gutverdienern für die schülerinnen
geben wir als staat für ihre bildung pro
schuljahr 8000 euro aus mein vorschlag
diese subventionen streichen im bildungs
investitionen verstärken will so weit
werden sie da der meinung von herrn
lindner subventionen für autos streichen
also erstmal das thema das wir eine
kostenkontrolle im bundeshaushalt
brauchen dass sie mit den ausgaben die
den deutschen steuerzahlern und bürger
nicht zugute kommen das ist ja das was
ich immer sage wir sind bei den kosten
viel zu hoch wir haben ein gigantisches
steueraufkommen und ich höre auch hier
in der diskussion immer nur die steuern
zu erhöhen wir müssen aber mit den
steuern runter wir müssen gerade für die
bürger die bürger richtig von ihnen habe
ich das nicht der lindner aber von den
anderen höre ich dass wir müssen mit den
steuern und abgaben runter um die
kleinen und mittleren einkommen die
familien zu entlasten da müssen wir
ansetzen und dementsprechend sagen wie
als ich die ja eben auch die co2
besteuerung es auch verfassungswidrig
haben sie eingeführt
muss abgeschafft werden dadurch geht den
pendlern der spritpreis und die
heizkosten durch die decke das eeg
abgeschafft das ist etwas was wirklich
überhaupt nicht geht seit 2004
hat sich
die hat sich das eeg
verzehnfacht und uns geht die energie
bepreisung durch die decke und wir
müssen natürlich mit der einkommensteuer
runter und dementsprechend müssen wir
darüber reden wie kommen wir auf der
kostenseite
runtergehen und da fallen mir ganz viele
kosten größen 1 die kosten durch die
illegale migration der durch die eu
umverteilungspolitik corona wiederaufbau
von
liebe frau hassel antworten wie alle
arbeiten auch das ist mir auch die zeit
nehmen denn sie haben die frage nach dem
finanzhaushalt gestellt genau das hatten
sie ja jetzt gemacht und das war die
frage und wir haben jetzt um
zurückzukommen zu finanzen und den punkt
abzubinden
eine gerne eine art schnelle fragerunde
an sie alle weil es den spagat abdeckt
und zwar wie entscheiden sie in den
kommenden jahren eher für einen
ausgeglichenen haushalt oder für nötige
investitionen fangen wir bei ihnen an
frau wissler wir brauchen investitionen
unbedingt den klimaschutz und
bezahlbares wohnen in die krankenhäuser
das haben wir vorher gesehen aber wir
brauchen eine andere steuerpolitik
einsatz der politik um mehreinnahmen zu
haben deswegen schon sechsmal
vermögenssteuer vor sehr hoch wir haben
für die wir haben für die nächsten jahre
50 milliarden investitionen vorgesehenen
bundeshaushalt in der finanzplanung die
die bundesregierung einstimmig
beschlossen hat das ist das was wir
brauchen an öffentlichen investitionen
stimme herrn lindner zu das größte teil
dessen was wir brauchen bei windenergie
bei leitungsnetzen bei gigabit netzwerk
sind privatwirtschaftliche investitionen
die da eine rolle spielen aber den teil
der öffentlich sein muss können wir
finanzieren und das heißt auch dass wir
im rahmen der regeln des grundgesetzes
in der lage sind eine expansive
investitionsstrategie zu fahren ohne
dass wir sie verletzten
den erwerber ausgeglichener haushalt
investitionen so wie jeder gute
unternehmer wirtschaftet bei konsumtiven
ausgaben muss der haushalt ausgeglichen
sein und investiven aufgaben sowie ein
unternehmen in maschinen investiert und
dafür kredite aufnimmt da muss es auch
investieren um ich kriege ich auch
finanz jetzt gehen wir
haben vor der pandemie erlebt keine
steuererhöhungen schuldenbremse
unterstadt hatte jedes jahr
mehreinnahmen weil die wirtschaft
gewachsen ist und viele menschen in
beschäftigung waren und das
unterscheidet mich von den drei linken
spd und grünen ich will keine
steuererhöhungen ich will die
schuldenbremse einhalten und ich will
alles tun dass wir wieder wachstum haben
damit wir wieder ressourcen haben um
dann zu investieren er sehe keine
aufweichung der schuldenbremse
steuersenkungen statt steuererhöhungen
um nämlich die private wirtschaft und
das private engagement der menschen zu
stärken immer wenn steuern erhöht wendt
gibt es am ende weniger steuereinnahmen
und wirtschaftlichen misserfolg also ist
das der zweite weg der dritte keine
europäische schulden union zu machen
wenn man einen großen beitrag erbracht
aber eine generelle einstieg wie es von
einigen in dem portal parteiprogramm
gewollt wird in europa und sms der
falsche weg das wollen wir auf keinen
fall und das letztes investitionen auf
der einen seite technologie haben
hightech viel zu machen investitionen in
auch viele soziale fragen ist um das
wohngeld geht dass er sich bei dem demo
noch angebaut aber was nicht passieren
kann eine generelle umverteilungs idee
zu entwickeln
das ist das ganze was von linker seite
ganz bewusst in den raum gestellt wird
das führt am ende zum gleichen wie bei
gerhard schröder hat so fünf arbeiten
habe viele gute trelle schon da passiert
genau das gleiche es gibt genau los wie
bei lafontaine und schröder viele viele
ideen viele viele experimente am ende
stand das land kurz vor dem ruin das
darf nicht passieren
sehr sympathisch was der csu-vorsitzende
gerade gesagt hat der bayerische
ministerpräsident hat aber gerade
neulich in einer regierungserklärung im
landtag gefragt ob die schuldenbremse
nicht verfassungsrechtlich einmal
überprüft werden müsste also insofern
eine neue in neue interessante
information die csu
ist euch sagen im fluss was diese fragen
kann sie rechne für mich ist für mich
ist in die laune auf schulden
schuldenbremse muss eingehalten werden
ist übrigens etwas anderes als ein
ausgeglichener haushalt weil im
konjunkturverlaufs kreditaufnahme in der
verfassung ermöglicht ist auf der
anderen seite keine steuererhöhungen das
ist für meine partei ein konzept von
zwei leitplanken innerhalb der
leitplanken müssen wir alles unternehmen
dass wir einen aufschwung bekommen
deutschland wächst nur mit 2,5 prozent
andere kommen besser aus der krise also
bitte nicht neuen bürokratismus in
deutschland schnellere
genehmigungsverfahren gezielte
entlastungen und dann wachsen dem staat
auch wieder mittel zu die für sinnvolle
soziale und ökologische fragen
eingesetzt werden können
die bürger entlasten die arbeitende
bevölkerung deutlich entlasten durch
steuer und abgabensenkungen sowie ich
das eben ausgeführt habe und man hat
enorm viel luft dafür indem man auf der
ausgabenseite des haushalts einfach
einsparungen trifft die eben nicht der
bevölkerung zugute kommen sondern
ein teil der ausgaben sind die auch aus
meiner sicht völlig völlig unnötig sind
und vielleicht noch eins zu eins ja ich
finde das sehr interessant die cdu/csu
ist ja auch in der regierung sähen das
längst machen können die steuern zu
senken das haben sie nicht getan und ich
denke mal das ist es auch dem wahlkampf
geschuldet dass sie das hier noch mal
ausgeführt haben aber sie haben es
letztendlich nie umgesetzt und
vielleicht auch noch mal dazu da haben
sie dann eben auch luft beim sozialen
wohnungsbau da dürfen wir ja eben nichts
dazu sagen aber ich noch ein satz liebe
frau hassel einsatz
die die bürokratisierung ist einfach zu
hoch auch da hätten die
regierungsparteien längst eingreifen
müssen dass wir schnellere
genehmigungsverfahren haben um eben also
das wohl eher eben gar nicht
angesprochen darum ist es ja so gar
nichts zu sagen richtig da war vielen
dank würden gerne zu einem thema kommt
es in diesem wahlkampf
unangemessener weise eigentlich kaum
eine rolle gespielt hat die viel
beschworenen zeitenwende hat ja auch
viel damit zu tun dass sich die welt um
uns herum fundamental verändert china
zeigt seine muskeln und uns unsere
abhängigkeit ein neuer kalter konfliktes
unterwegs welche rolle spielen wir darin
und zu welchem preis frankreich wurde
gerade bei in gigantischen
rüstungsauftrag ausgebootet hat sogar
seinen botschafter aus den usa zurück
beordert herr scholz stehen sie an der
seite frankreichs und wie würden sie als
ein möglicher regierungschef damit
umgehen
wir müssen mit frankreich zusammen dafür
sorgen dass europa vorankommt und
deshalb haben wir hier auch eine enge
partnerschaft das finde ich ist ganz
ganz wichtig und die irritationen die
die französische regierung hat über die
art und weise wie das da gelaufen ist
mit dem neuen rüstungsvertrag den die
usa mit australien und großbritannien
auf den weg gebracht haben für die
atomgetriebenen u-boote die kann ich
sehr nachvollziehen und auch die ganze
deutsche regierung im übrigen wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass wir ein starkes
souveränes europa bekommen das ist aus
meiner sicht die wichtigste aufgabe die
wir als deutsche haben wir sind das
große land mitten drin in der
europäischen union mit der größten
bevölkerung der größten wirtschaftskraft
und deshalb werden wir dafür sorge
tragen müssen dass dieses europa mehr
mit einer stimme sprechen kann die welt
wird mal zehn milliarden einwohner haben
dann wird es viele mächte geben nicht
nur die usa china und russland sondern
auch viele andere länder des wieder
aufgeschriebenen steigenden asiens korea
japan indonesien malaysia indien um eine
zügige zu nennen und aus meiner sicht
ist es deshalb ganz ganz zentral dass
wir immer sagen es gibt da prinzipien
die für uns wichtig sind zu denen zählt
die starke europäische union weil wir
sonst keine rolle spielen dazu zählt
aber auch die zusammenarbeit mit den usa
gerade auch wenn es zu kritisch würden
wir jetzt und dazu zählt natürlich auch
die zusammenarbeit in der nato wir haben
relativ viele fragen aus dem bereich
also insofern kurze antworten helfen uns
auch das thema breit aufzustellen herr
laschet schmollen die franzosen zu
unrecht wie ihr außenexperte norbert
röttgen gesagt hat und an sie als
potenziellen kanzler wie würden sie denn
mit welcher politik verhindern dass
europa zerrieben wird in diesem
kräftespiel zwischen den beiden
supermächten china und usa aber vielen
dank vor hass und der call dass sie das
thema hier ansprechen am 3 tri elle
gehabt über diese frage außen europa
entwicklungspolitik ist so gut wie kein
wort gefallen ganz europa schaut darauf
was entsteht jetzt für eine neue
deutsche regierung weil deutschland
immer in europa ein wichtiger staat ist
der durch seine wirtschaftliche stärke
europa zusammenhält und
gleichzeitig eine politische macht ist
auf die viele schauen und deshalb glaube
ich dass wir ein souveränes ein
stärkeres europa brauchen insbesondere
in der außen und sicherheitspolitik
namen in afghanistan gesehen wenn die
amerikaner abziehen sind wir nicht
einmal in der lage den flughafen von
kabul zu sichern deshalb will ich im
bundeskanzleramt einen nationalen
sicherheitsrat einrichten der alle
unsere informationen bündelt und die
außenpolitik stärkt und zum zweiten
brauchen wir mehr europa wir müssen mit
einer stimme sprechen wir müssen
gemeinsame projekte beginnen auch
rüstungsprojekte beginnen um auch einmal
handeln zu können wenn die usa sich
zurückziehen und da sie eine aufgabe die
die nächste regierung haben wird wo wir
wirkt die militärischen drohungen im
südchinesischen meer die unterdrückung
der demokratie in hongkong
die uiguren sie fordern einen deutlich
härteren kurs gegenüber china was heißt
das konkret welche hebel würden sie
ansetzen wir haben erlebt dass durch die
lücke die europa und es lag vor allen
dingen daran weil das größte land in
europa nämlich die bundesrepublik
deutschland ausgefallen ist dass sich
die lücke die europa außenpolitisch
geschaffen hat autoritäre kräfte nicht
nur in china sondern wie russland diese
lücke gefüllt ausgefallen meinen sie zu
freundlich ja bzw zu schweigsam oder
eben nicht gemeinsam als europäer agiert
also nehmen wir jetzt mal zum beispiel
mit blick auf die situation dass zu
beginn des jahres eine neue
us-administration gewählt worden ist die
endlich diesen neuen aufbruch für
demokratien weltweit einen neustart
gegeben hat und was war die erste
reaktion von der bundesregierung von der
großen koalition mit china ein
investitionsabkommen zu schließen was im
übrigen auch alle an unsere eigenen
europäischen partner ein von latz
geknallt hat weil man das gar nicht
gemeinsam in europa beschlossen hat
deswegen der reichenberger auf eis ich
möchte dafür sorgen dass wir zu einer
gemeinsamen europäischen china politik
kommen nicht die einen gegen die anderen
ausgespielt werden damit wir im
wettstreit dieser systeme als europa
deutlich machen wir haben eine eigene
strategische souveränität und das heißt
ein neues kapitel in der europäischen
außen- und auch
menschenrechtspolitik endlich auf zu
schlagen herr lindner sie haben ja auch
sie kennen sich in china aus sie waren
darunter weg sie haben oft die china
politik der kanzlerin kritisiert als ich
sag ihnen meinen worten zu wirtschafts
orientiert und zu unkritisch gegenüber
den menschenrechten dh
wenn sie sagen in einer regierung der
sie mit angehören würden wir müssen eine
härtere politik gegenüber china fahren
würden sie dann auch zu mitarbeitern von
unternehmen gehen den in die augen
schauen und sagen sorry aber ihr job
fällt vielleicht weg weil wir china
unter druck gesetzt haben volkswagen zum
beispiel verkauft fast jedes zweite auto
ins reich der mitte es gibt eine
alternative
noch dazu zunächst sehe ich das
investitionsabkommen mit china ebenfalls
kritisch wir müssen unsere interessen
und unsere werte gleichermaßen vertreten
ich bin sicher dass unsere produkte so
gut sind dass es von chinesischer seite
da keine zurückweisung gebe wir sollten
aber auch das klumpenrisiko wenn man das
mal so nennt handel mit china dadurch
reduzieren dass wir mehr
freihandelsabkommen schließen das
freihandelsabkommen mit kanada hat die
große koalition nicht vermocht in vier
jahren zu ratifizieren
wir brauchen mit südamerika mit den
asian staaten handelsabkommen damit auch
für den deutschen mittelstand der export
dahin erleichtert wird ich muss einen
damit verbundenen zweiten punkt machen
europa muss tatsächlich handlungsfähig
werden wir müssen den binnenmarkt als
wachstumsmotor stärken bei digitalen
dienstleistungen auch im bereich der
banken zweitens wir brauchen innerhalb
europas mehr gemeinsamkeit bei der
klimapolitik bitte nicht nur ein
deutscher sonderweg
bei der frage der migrationspolitik
schutz der aussengrenzen gemeinsame
außen und sicherheitspolitik
ich rate ab ich bin gleich fertig ich
rate ab bei der vergemeinschaftung von
schulden oder beim gedanken dass nur mit
staatlichen investitionen wachstum
erfolgen könnte das wird nicht gelingen
letzter punkt die usa sind für uns ein
unverzichtbarer strategischer partner
und deshalb muss eine zukünftige
deutsche bundesregierung mehr tun um aus
einer europäischen perspektive
das transatlantische verhältnis zu
verbessern ein konkreter vorschlag
es gibt gemeinsame kabinettssitzungen
der bundesregierung mit china mit
frankreich mit israel warum gibt es so
etwas nicht mit unserem wichtigsten
verbündeten der usa leiden wir gerne
noch beim thema china herr söder der
ausländische berater der ehemalige
berater der kanzlerin hat bezeichnet
china jetzt als einen totalitären staat
mehr härte gegenüber china klingt ja gut
aber was bedeutet das und was sagen sie
dann arbeiten beispielsweise in münchen
die davon betroffen sind zunächst einmal
finde ich der eindruck vermittelt wird
dass deutschland seit vielen jahren die
frau per bus sei keine schlechte
außenpolitik macht weiß ich zurück ich
finde unsere bundeskanzlerin hat uns
durch schwerste krisen globale krisen
gut gebracht sie hat dieses land einfach
gut beschützt und hat ein ansehen im
ausland wo sich manche wünschen würden
dass jene im leben so ein ansehen
bekommen
zwischen zu reden macht nicht richtiger
das zweite ist ich glaube dass wir uns
auf krisensituationen besser vorbereiten
müssen in der welt indem wir die
bundeswehr starken das haben jetzt auch
in afghanistan sind wie wir haben asche
zu recht sagt deswegen wir auch der
einsatz gegen bundeswehr abschaffung der
bundeswehr ausstieg aus der nato
katastrophales zeigen internationale
unsicherheit würde uns in europa
komplett isoliert und dürfe auf keinen
fall passieren und ist dritter wir
brauchen eine außenpolitik die die
richtige balance zwischen den werten für
die wir stehen auch im wettbewerb der
systeme aber eben umgekehrt auch unsere
interessen jedes land der welt denkt
auch an seinen interessen und wir in
europa müssen es auch tun und es sind
glaube ich einfach mit china braucht es
sicherlich einen konstruktiven dialog
nicht kuscheln aber es braucht auch
nicht eine komplette belehrung
dogmatisch das heißt natürlich müssen
wir auch die wirtschaftlichen interessen
sehen die wir da haben china ist unser
wichtigster markt ging es nicht nur für
automobil wichtig und ehrlicherweise ich
sehe jetzt nicht an dass wir aufgrund
mancher ideen und auch eine etwas
unreifen einstellung zur welt wie
vielleicht bei den grünen waren am ende
millionen arbeitsplätze in deutschland
gefährden da braucht es eine richtige
eine kluge und eine strategische
ausgewogenheit und balance ob das jetzt
naive frau wer mag da werden sie
sicherlich was gegen sagen sollen aber
laut bdi hat er ja auch mit klagen der
aktion dass man nicht mit zwangsarbeiter
auf den europäischen binnenmarkt kommen
sollte dialog und härte in der china
politik genau der richtige weg wir
können nur das ein pilger chinesen
ins spiel bringen und frau weil das
wissen vielleicht nicht alle sie haben
ja in china gelebt eine zeit kennen das
land also auch und wir haben ja gerade
den dissenz eigentlich menschenrechte
auch über wirtschaftspolitik mit
anzusprechen oder eben nationale
interessen oder beides geht beides
deshalb ganz konkret für sie wirtschaft
first
beides also sie haben grundsätzlich wenn
sie einen handelspartner haben haben sie
auch interessen und diese interessen
müssen ausgeglichen werden im fall von
der bundesrepublik deutschland ist es so
dass die usa als auch die volksrepublik
china
unsere wichtigsten export absatzmärkte
sind und da ist muss ich eben auch
laptops und das muss dass muss sich
natürlich auch in der außenpolitischen
interessen lage wieder schlag heißt das
wer wie was das heißt dass wir zu
gute beziehungen brauchen und ich rate
davon ab vor allem
im fall von der volksrepublik china mit
einer keule so wie es frau berbalk hier
gerade angesprochen hat
darüber zukommen denn volks die
volksrepublik china ist viel zu wichtig
geworden und wird auch noch viel
wichtiger so dass wir ein entspannteres
verhältnis mit den chinesen brauchen was
ja auch im übrigen die bundesregierung
früher auch hatte weil sie eben auch
ganz klar die wirtschafts interessen
vertreten also verzichtet haben viele
forschungs und entwicklungslabor dort
vor ort im übrigen in dem moment stehen
hier reden und kauf von korea
unternehmen wo wir reden wo wir gerade
darüber im moment ich lasse mich gerade
lassen sie mich diesen punkt machen
gerade wo wir darüber sprechen wird in
china der erste thorium reaktor gebaut
so viel zu forschungs und
entwicklungsleistungen der volksrepublik
china das heißt wir können in einer
internationalen zusammenarbeit mit china
profitieren und wir können voneinander
lernen und ich rate davon ab in einen
dialog abzubrechen oder den chinesen vor
den kopf zu stoßen ich halte das aber
für eine lüge
falsche worte ich möchte ja niemand über
die frage noch mal wiederholen weil sie
glaube ich erhellend ist bestehens wie
stehen sie dazu frau weiter dass mit
chinesischem kapital deutsche
unternehmen gekauft werden und das
europäischen unternehmen in gleicher
weise in china nicht möglich ist also
eine ganz kurze antwort an unseren
dritten moderator ja warum soll ich
darauf kurz antwort und wenn er mir so
eine lange frage stellt darauf kann man
ja auch vernünftig antworten oder also
erstmal gilt gilt gilt bei
kapitalinvestition der freie markt das
ist einfach so das wissen sie auch und
ich halte da eben auch überhaupt gar
nichts von dass wir kein verhältnis auf
dem investitions markt auf augenhöhe
haben und da ist natürlich auch wieder
die bundesregierung ist dort gefragt
dort für eine entspannung zu sorgen und
unsere ich würde sagen
genauso habe ich ja gerade gesagt schon
vorweisen und herr lindner zur not nach
der sendung fortgesetzt wird wir haben
qualität einfach nur lesen erklärt in
treffen frau wyss nach ihrer partei wird
ja kaum die position vertreten
wirtschaft zuerst sondern eher die
menschenrechte betont dennoch
hört man sehr wenig laute kritik von
ihrer partei entschieden
na ja ganz deutlich sagen wir dass
menschenrechte entscheidend sind und
auch die rechte von beschäftigten und
von gewerkschaften zum beispiel und das
ist auch an die adresse von deutschen
unternehmen der gute geschäfte machen in
china das die insbesondere die
arbeitnehmerrechte eingehalten werden
müssen ich will nur vielleicht kurze an
einer stelle herrn söder wir sprechen
wenn er sagt deutschland hat eine
erfolgreiche außenpolitik gemacht also
wir haben das desaster von afghanistan
gerade erlebt 20 jahre lang krieg 100000
zivile tote 12 5 milliarden euro hat die
bundeswehr einsatz gekostet und jetzt
die taliban wieder da und sie sind
stärker als je zuvor weil sie vermutlich
jetzt auf der ami zurückgreifen können
die 20 jahre lang ausgebildet und
ausgerüstet wurde vom westen der einsatz
in mali steht kurz vor dem scheitern
lassen sie uns darüber reden wenn wir
über europäische union reden dass man
zulässt dass tagtäglich menschen im
mittelmeer ertrinken oder darüber dass
wie die deutsche politik ist war also
ich meine dass die türkei weiterhin
waffenlieferungen bekommt aus
deutschland nato-partner übrigens und
dort krieg gegen die kurden führt die
opposition und ich kann nicht
feststellen dass diese bundesregierung
eine erfolgreiche außenpolitik gemacht
hätte sondern es wäre völlig inhalte
auch so lich und alles andere hätte mich
jetzt auch bewundert unter hier war
jetzt mehrfach das wort bei der uran ist
dann schon gefallen und in der tat es
war ja schon angeklungen ist das ein
militärisches debakel die usa haben uns
vor vollendete tatsachen gestellt mit
diesem
unabgesprochenen über alten abzug aus
afghanistan herr söder sie waren jetzt
länger nicht in der runde deshalb die
erste frage an sie die kanzlerin hat
danach gesagt wir müssen in zukunft
einsätze kleiner fassen was heißt dass
nur noch deutsche soldaten in
auslandseinsätzen wenn unsere sicherheit
bedroht ist oder aber gibt es noch den
vernetzten ansatz bauen wir noch schulen
und brunnen je nachdem was sozusagen
auch die möglichkeiten sind also zum
einmal glaube ich bei afghanistan der
völlig überstürzten abzug der amerikaner
ist ja die ursache für all die ganzen
herausforderungen und das ist ja ein
schon ein schlag für die glaubwürdigkeit
des westens gewesen das haben wir auch
immer gesagt keine schuld daran übrigens
die bundeswehr an die soldatinnen
soldaten haben dort einen großartigen
dienst geleistet und das muss man
ausdrücklich sein gegenüber auch den
familien der gefallenen sie haben
unglaublich viel dazu beigetragen 20
jahre übrigens auch terrorismus zu
verhindern das muss man sagen die frage
welche ansprüche ansprüche während
stellen also für die bundeswehr es die
hauptaufgabe ist sicherheit zu
gewährleisten wir können nation building
probieren aber es wird nicht überall
klappen in bestimmten teilen der welt
darauf müssen die einsätze auch
präzisiert werden sie müssen
konkretisiert werden was der auftrag ist
ich glaube auch dass die bundeswehr
einen bestimmten bereichen
gleichberechtigt mit anderen partnern
wenn zb mit den französischen partnern
sind müssen wir die gleichen robusten
einsätze fahren und ich kann nur eines
sagen das wichtigste ist überhaupt
souveränität zu haben mehr geld für die
bundeswehr ich glaube 40 länder der welt
haben bewaffnete drohnen um ihre
soldatinnen soldaten zu schützen
teile der spd haben das immer verhindert
ich halte es für falsch wir müssen die
beste technologie entwickelt und die
bundeswehr einen zustand versetzen
international dem status deutschlands
der größe dem schutz seiner eigenen
bürger dann am ende auch die sicherheit
und souveränität zwar die frage an den
finanzminister die bundeswehr wurde ja
so wird es von kritikern gesehen jahre
lang kaputt gespart und ist relativ
schlecht ausgerüstet müssten wir jetzt
nicht sagen dass zwei prozent ziel der
nato ist eigentlich noch zu wenig um ein
funktionierendes sicherheitsbündnis ohne
die usa aufzubauen vielleicht sollten
wir mal bei den fakten bleiben die
bundeswehr hat erhebliche mittel
steigerungen bekommen im laufe dieser
legislaturperiode
was sich völlig richtig finde scheint
aber wir haben recht wir haben eine
steigerung in dieser zeit von dem
haushaltsentwurf den ich übernommen habe
für das jahr 2018 bis zu dem der für das
nächste jahr geplant ist von 36% da geht
es um viele viele milliarden die jedes
jahr zusätzlich fließen und ich halte
das auch für richtig weil die bundeswehr
hatte in der zeit das muss ich sagen der
schwarz gelben koalitionäre schlechteste
zeit da es wirklich sparpolitik bei der
bundeswehr gemacht worden und das haben
wir jetzt gründlich beendet und das ist
auch richtig so also ich stimme zu wenn
gesagt wird wir müssen eine gute
ausstattung der bundeswehr organisieren
stimme auch zu was er gesagt hat wir
müssen unseren soldaten soldaten sehr
sehr dankbar sein für den einsatz und
die einsätze diese überall in der welt
leisten das ist gefährlich und jedes mal
wenn wir diese entscheidungen im
bundestag treffen und wenn die
bundesregierung das vor schlicht müssen
wir immer im blick haben das wirklich
gefährliche einsätze auch die kleinen
und das darf nie vergessen werden und
deshalb die regel sondern ist dass die
das machen sie reden dass sie es so gut
machen sie reden alle jetzt davon europa
muss gestärkt werden wir müssen uns auf
eine neue zeit einstellen die usa haben
andere interessen dann reicht das ja
trotzdem nicht es ist erst mal sehr viel
geld und das ist auch das was wir im
vergleich zu den anderen nationen die
diese größenordnung haben leisten können
was wir bisher gemacht haben und ich
will gerne zu sagen dass wir im rahmen
der wirtschaftlichen möglichkeiten auch
in den nächsten jahren weitere
steigerung des verteidigungshaushaltes
brauchen nicht dazu auch stehe dass das
weiter so gehen wird ich hatte ja gesagt
wir haben die kräfte die im sozusagen
die rede konnten prüfen sie sind da
relativ weit oben und frau wissler ist
relativ weit hinten deshalb freue mich
jetzt zu ihnen frau wissler also wenn
wir über den einsatz deutscher soldaten
im ausland reden dann reden wir ja über
auch und vor allem über nato aus
einsätze
eigentlich will die linke die nato
abschaffen jetzt macht die linke schon
gewisse morgan gaben vor
koalitionsgesprächen das macht man
eigentlich erst danach und ihr kandidat
bartsch hat sich da flexibel gezeigt hat
gesagt naja die nato auflösung sei eine
langfristige vision und nichts für die
kommende legislaturperiode aber dass mit
ihnen abgesprochen sehen sie das genauso
das sind keine wie sie es jetzt genannt
haben irgendwie zu gehen auf andere
sondern das ist die gleichstellung
unserer position so wie sie im programm
drin steht dass wir gesagt haben ja wir
kritisieren die nato
halten die nato für völlig über kommen
und wir halten es für notwendig dass wir
zu einer anderen sicherheitsarchitektur
kommen wir kritisieren sehr konkret zwei
punkte das ist dass zwei prozent sieht
man muss das ja mal plastisch machen was
das bedeuten würde deutschland gibt im
moment 50 milliarden euro aus für die
rüstung das wären dann noch mal 25
milliarden extra muss man einfach nur
wissen was das heißt wir sind der
meinung mehr rüstung macht die welt
nicht sicherer und wir brauchen das geld
auch dringend woanders haben wir beim
krone gesehen ein pflegenotstand werden
marode schulen wir haben zu wenig
bezahlbaren wohnraum wir wollen nicht 25
milliarden mehr für die rüstung ausgeben
bewaffnete drohnen lehnen wir strikt ab
wir haben es übrigens in afghanistan
gerade gesehen
haben weil ihr redet porto sehr weit
unten war das haben ja das aufgeholt das
haben jetzt auch gut aber noch einmal
konkret also auch sie sagen nato auf los
ist eine langfristige vision wäre nichts
für das teil der bundesregierung selbst
wenn ihr einer meinung wäre nicht auf
einen schlag die nato auflösen kann das
ist ja nur jetzt mit diesen weise wohl
gerne darüber reden dass wir das 2
prozent ziehen wir wollen nicht weiter
aufrüsten und wir würden gerne wissen
wie wir mit der türkei umgehen die
normal an nato-partner ist werden der
weiter waffen geliefert er schaut man
weiter weg bei der
menschenrechtssituation um
grundsätzliche meinung dass wenn über
außenpolitik geredet wird wir vielleicht
nicht immer nur beim militär
verteidigungen nato reden sollten
sondern mal über die internationalen
klimaschutz haben wir heute gar nicht
über die weltwirtschaftsordnung
freihandelsabkommen also das sind ja
auch
international schulte dahinter gleich
und wir haben auch gar nicht die ganze
zeit darüber geredet und damit wir haben
auch gar nicht vorgeworfen allgemeinen
diskurs findet es sehr stark eine
verengung auf diese militärischen fragen
statt die haben ja eben über die
freihandelsabkommen explizit geredet
doch plötzlich auch einen wichtigen
punkt in entwicklungszusammenarbeit zum
beispiel da können wir auch mal das 0,7
prozent ziel erreichen statt dem 2
prozent zu die nach gut damit wir
möglichst viele themen noch ansprechen
können wir reden ja schon lange über
außenpolitik aber machen wir eine
schnell fragerunde mit unterschiedlichen
themen und
zwar zunächst an sie frau wissler wie
hätten sie persönlich wenn sie im
bundestag wehren abgestimmt ortskräfte
durch die bundeswehr aus kabul
ausfliegen lassen ja oder nein im juni
haben wir dazu einen antrag eingebracht
dem haben wir zugestimmt die grünen an
dem zustand hatte
hatte al arabija und mit nein gestimmt
deshalb würde ich mich interessieren
hinterher wir haben es ja rechtzeitig
beantragt und soll nachträglich
mandatierung als die abstimmung
stattfinden ist der bundeswehreinsatz
schon beendet war daher nicht enthalten
weil ich bin für die evakuierung ich
habe kritik an der art und weise der
umsetzung und deswegen enthalten aber
wie
das format ist ja oder nein
herr scholz atombomben aus deutschland
abziehen ja oder nein
wir haben internationale verpflichtungen
die wir einhalten müssen das kind keine
einseitigen entscheidung aus deutschland
frau berg bewaffnete drohnen für die
bundeswehr ja oder nein
wenn geklärt ist für welche einsätze wer
sie brauchen weil die große lehre aus
afghanistan ist dass man vor einsätzen
definiert was sind eigentlich unsere
ziele was brauchen wir an material das
heißt dafür müssen die kriterien
entsprechend geschaffen werden damit
dann der einsatz auch sinn machen kann
das waren ja das war ein jahr mit den
kriterien die man dafür braucht weil
blankoschecks in der außenpolitik zu
verteilen ohne zu wissen für welche
situation ist hochriskant und das sollte
man nicht tun hat nord stream in betrieb
nehmen ja oder ja wir brauchen dich mal
was wirtschaftliche projekt weil wir
wenn wir aus allen energie hinaus
steigen wir natürlich in den nächsten
jahren gas brauchen wichtig ist mir dass
das was die bundesregierung verabredet
hat jetzt auch umgesetzt wird nämlich
eine geopolitische garantie dass die
ukraine dadurch keine nachteile erleiden
hat sollte russland das in frage stellen
wird das projekt unmittelbar gestoppt
herr söder seenotrettung durch die eu
wieder einführen ja oder nein hilfe ja
aber gleichzeitig auch schutz der
grenzen und insbesondere mehr hilfe vor
ort ist glaube ich das allerwichtigste
übrigens auch mit den anrainerstaaten in
afghanistan hilfe vor ort das ist die
beste hilfe damit sich niemand auf den
weg machen muss aber seenotrettung
wieder einführen habe ich nicht
verstanden ja hier helfen immer wieder
aber nicht sozusagen eine grundlegende
veränderung der derzeitigen politik herr
lindner ukraine in die nato ja oder nein
nein
endlich mal einer mit einer klaren ja
oder nein
polen um jeden preis in der eu halten ja
oder nein ja
auch ein kleines jahr und java vielen
dank fast alle parteien lassen ist bei
unserem nächsten thema nicht an großen
worten fehlen den klimawandel zu stoppen
ist eine menschheitsaufgabe heißt es bei
der spd die grünen sprechen von der
existenz frage unserer zeit die union
von der bewahrung der schöpfung zu der
das christliche menschenbild
verpflichtet
wir wollen gerne noch mal eine schnelle
fragerunde anschließen nur durch
innovation also ganz ohne verzicht wird
man die erderwärmung ja nicht aufhalten
können deswegen ungefähr eine frage an
sehen alle was verzichten sie ganz
persönlich froh wenn wir bei ihnen
anfangen dürfen jetzt schon
auf unnötige strecken mit dem fahrzeug
dann benutze ich lieber das fahrrad und
auf sparsamkeit im verbrauch von
ressourcen
berlin
ich teile ihre voraussetzung der frage
nicht milliarden menschen auf der welt
können nicht auf wohlstand oder
wirtschaftliche perspektive verzichten
weil sie gar keine haben deshalb ist die
aufgabe deutschlands durch
spitzentechnologie eine freie
lebensweise wirtschaftliche perspektive
mit dem klimaschutz zu verbinden und die
nationen der ingenieurin und techniker
kann das vom wasserstoff windpark über
den synthetischen kraftstoff
ich bin persönlich ich bin persönlich
klimaneutral weil ich jedes jahr
die tonnen co2 die ich persönlich
verbraucher im europäischen
zertifikatehandel ja schon lange
also ich glaube auch fest daran dass
nicht verzicht die frage sondern
veränderung und dass verbote von
vornherein es falsche sind müssen der
angebote setzen ich persönlich war wie
heute beispielsweise mit der bahn her
statt mit dem auto ich hätte auch eine
video schalte gerne gemacht aber das hat
er mich falsch ausgelegt und umgekehrt
auch ich reduziere auch und es fehlt an
den bayern gar nicht so leicht den
fleischkonsum beispielsweise und
gesünder und auch klimabewusste auch
mich zu ernähren wie gesagt ich bin auf
dem weg dazu ja richtig was kennen
hannah etwas gibt es bei ihnen letzteres
tue ich auch als nicht bayer
ansonsten sind ja vielleicht ja aber
nicht
und ich teile aber ebenso diese
verzichts
verzichts gefühl nicht ich war ein
elektromobil das fahrzeug und das macht
spaß das ist schöner als das fahrzeug
das ich vorher hatte und deshalb glaube
ich dass das alles auch spaß machen kann
klimaneutral zu werden regenschauer
warum nennen das einsparungen wie auch
immer ja das sprache ich ein aber das
macht dazu noch spaß macht ihnen spaß
beim einspannen da jetzt alle solche öko
sind es ja schön wenn die nächste
bundesregierung dann auch endlich hier
klimaneutral wird ich fahre seit sieben
wochen im wahlkampf mit dem bus durch
die gegen auch gerne mal nachts um im
inland nicht zufrieden mit ihrem
wahlkampf bus
ich finde man muss sehr vorsichtig sein
mit so einer antwort ich könnte jetzt
sagen auch wahrheitsgemäß und richtig
ich kaufe gerne regionale lebensmittel
ein das ist ein beitrag dazu aber ich
finde es gehört auch zur ehrlichkeit
dazu dass man als ein politiker der mit
sicherheits geschützten fahrzeugen
unterwegs ist mit vielen flugzeugen
fliegt nicht den eindruck erweckt als
sei man der beste beim reduzieren des
co2 abdruck das ist etwas das ich als
zynisch empfinden würde ich finde
wahrheit hilft hier auch wenn ich mit
dem fahrrad ins ministerium fahrer wird
sich drei oder vier mal gemacht haben
dann sind auch noch viele andere dabei
und das ist keine verbesserung der
klimasituation
für mich und deshalb finde ich muss man
da ehrlich sein damit kein falscher
eindruck entsteht ich will aber
loswerden wir werden da gleich ja
vielleicht noch darüber diskutieren dass
ich auch glaube dass das wichtigste was
wir zum schutz des klimas machen müssen
innovationen sind wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass wir die erneuerbaren
energien ausbauen damit wir den strom
bekommen den wir benötigen damit das co2
neutralen stahl co2 110 gibt damit für
klimaneutrale zement wirtschaft haben
automobilwirtschaft und maschinenbau das
geht auch wir können also wirklich ein
besseres leben führen ohne
einschränkungen in der show andere 740
ist frage auch zu ende führen frau
wissen worauf verzichten sie persönlich
oder sparen ein
hier denke ich vernünftig mit energie um
und benutzten öffentliche verkehrsmittel
waren immer das gilt sowohl im
fernverkehr der bahn als auch im öpnv
was sie aber auch gar nicht so unbedingt
als verzicht
begreifen würde sondern oftmals geht es
ja auch deutlich schneller ja und ich
bin seit vielen jahren aktiv in
klimaschutz bewegung die auch morgen
wieder auf die straße gehen weil ich
glaube dass es notwendig ist die
menschen die sich engagieren auch zu
unterstützen ob das gegen abholzung von
wäldern ist oder für die einhaltung der
klimaschutzziele eben auch dort diese
protestbewegung zu unterstützen gut dann
hätte man jetzt in der persönlichen
runde schon ein bisschen gemischt aber
kommen wir zu etwas wirklich ernsten
politischen diese bundesregierung hatte
hat sich ein klimagesetz gegeben in dem
sie sich verpflichtet hat sofort
maßnahmen zu erlassen um gegenzusteuern
wenn bei den einzelnen sektoren die
ziele gerissen werden die werden im
moment drastisch gerissen wo bleiben die
sofortmaßnahmen wo wollen sie gegen
steuern
und die bundesregierung fragen ja die
sagen was eigentlich vertreter naja ich
kann ihnen sagen was wir machen werden
wenn ich bundeskanzler bin wir werden
das klimaschutzgesetz mit seinem
sektoren in jedem bereich
angleichen müssen durch maßnahmen
unterlegen müssen der co2 preis ein
einstieg werden weitere vorgesehen
welche aber entscheidend ja jetzt kommt
mein argument eben entscheidend ist
nicht in dem klein klein der maßnahmen
zu bleiben
[Musik]
jetzt hat sich die regierung gebe ja wir
wollen aber doch klimaschutzziele
erreichen geben und wir wollen co2
reduzieren und wenn es uns deshalb
gelingt und da sind wir mittendrin
stahlproduktion nicht mehr mit kohle und
eisenerz sondern mit wasserstoff zu
machen die chemische industrie
umzugestalten unsere industrien
umzugestalten dann leisten da
gleichzeitig den ausstieg aus den
fossilen brennstoffen wie der braunkohle
jetzt voranzutreiben
dann leisten wir dazu einen
substanziellen beitrag um die ziele des
klimaschutzgesetzes zu erreichen das ist
die aufgabe man kann das noch mal alles
in sektoren klein herunterrechnen ich
will sie nur verstehen und dann gar
nicht weiter aufhalten können nein aber
ich will sie verstehen dass das was sie
sagen es das sind maßnahmen aber es sind
nicht die die das klimagesetz der
jetzigen regierung sich gegeben hat also
würde dieses gesellschaft hin am kanzler
nee das muss ja ganz konkret kann ja
aber ich war ich deshalb habe ich dieses
klein-klein in gesetzen zu denken muss
man erfüllen aber die aufgabe ist eine
viel größere die aufgabe ist eine
größere unsere industriegesellschaft
umzuwandeln 6 prozent des co2 ausstoßes
in deutschland ist stahl wenn uns das
gelingt ist das ein so großer schub und
wir sind ja mittendrin in diesem prozess
dann wird das mehr erreichen als viele
kleine maßnahmen die wir darauf
geschrieben aber wäre trotzdem müssen
die erfüllt werden und an denen wird ja
auch stück für stück von jedem ressort
gearbeitet frau veronica ferres ist sie
nämlich dann wenn wir bei exekutiven
defiziten sind wenn man sich zwei
bundesländer anschaut wo sie entweder
den ministerpräsidenten stellen oder
auch an der regierung beteiligt sind
werden da auch nicht mehr windräder
gebaut
weil die regelung für die windkraft die
zentrale weichenstellung findet auf
bundesebene statt und genau das ist
jetzt die frage bei dieser
bundestagswahl
schaffen wir so wie andere generationen
bei historischen momenten in unserer
geschichte auch einen echten aufbruch
beschreiben erschaffen haben weil die
mutig gesagt haben wir schlagen jetzt
ein neues kapitel auf schaffen wir das
jetzt auch als zukünftige generation
deutschland in den nächsten 20 jahren
klimaneutral zu machen
und das ist die aufgabe unserer zeit und
das bedeutet jetzt ein klimaschutz
sofort programm aufzulegen 100 tage
sofortprogramm wo wir für jeden
einzelnen sektor und das unterscheidet
uns grün von der cdu das unterscheidet
uns von der spd für jeden einzelnen
sektor sagen das müssen wir jetzt tun
kohleausstieg vorziehen emissionsfreie
autos landwirtschaft in den nächsten 20
jahren kinder neutral gebäude und stahl
und das ist nicht nur eine frage von
klimaschutz sondern es ist mittlerweile
auch eine frage von unserer
internationalen wettbewerbsfähigkeit yam
gerade über china geredet und china hat
jetzt verkündet im ausland keine
kohlekraftwerke mehr zu finanzieren
sondern in zukunft energie partnerschaft
dem erneuerbaren bereichen zu machen das
heißt auch wenn wir jetzt nicht als
erster kontinent klimaneutral werden als
europäerinnen und europäer dann
verpassen wir unsere historische chance
sowie generation vor uns für den
wohlstand in deutschland gehörte er
herein klimagerechten wohl schwer
lindner sie hatten schon motto gott
gesagt jetzt als frau berbalk geredet
hat deshalb frage ich sie ich weiß die
fdp das haben sie ja auch gerade gesagt
sagt setzt auf innovation das ist auch
richtig und wichtig so aber man kann
nicht planen wann erfindungen und
innovationen
funktionieren und greifen wir haben aber
eine großem zeitdruck dabei den haben
wir gerade festgestellt was also wenn
die große innovation auf sich warten
lässt sind denn die konkreten maßnahmen
der fdp um irgendwie noch das pariser
klima abkommen einzuhalten das pariser
klimaabkommen werden wir nur global
einhalten können das kann deutschland
nicht alleine wir können einen
wertvollen beitrag leisten ich glaube
wie eben gesagt indem wir modellstandort
für bestimmte technologien sein können
und werden die woanders eingesetzt
werden da müssen wir richtig vorgehen
wenn frau baerbock über china spricht
dann darf sie nicht davon schweigen das
in deutschland daimler erklärt keine
verbrennungsmotoren mehr zu bauen aber
in china ein motorenwerk für
verbrennungsmotoren baut daimler
das zeigt wir brauchen eine globale
perspektive ist der vorschlag
hassel die die maßnahmen und
innovationen liegen doch vor denken sie
an basf und rwe die wollen den größten
co2 emittenten unseres landes dem
chemiewerk das chemiewerk in
ludwigshafen ein prozent der gesamten
deutschen co2 emissionen aus dem werk
das wollen die elektrifizieren
dekarbonisierung wissen sie was die
sagen sie brauchen kein geld vom staat
die bitten auch nicht um geduld die
verlangen nur schnelle planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren und da sehe ich
die aufgabe wir müssen nicht wie frau
berbalk das angeregt hat alles noch
weiter plan staatlich zentral lenken in
jedem sektor aber die werbende
planungssicherheit ich sage ja noch mal
gerade was die was die wirtschaft
tatsächlich will die wollen nicht diese
sektor ziel es ist viel zu kleinteilig
csu und spd haben zu verantworten dass
im bereich der mobilität die sektor
ziele de facto nicht erreichbar sind mit
egal was man macht in den nächsten
jahren die sektor ziele in der mobilität
sind nicht erreichbar also wir brauchen
ein co2 limit technologieoffenheit und
dann gibt es viele die privates kapital
und know how haben die in klimaschutz
investieren wollen in ihrem wahlprogramm
steht sogar warm zeiten hätten immer zu
einer blüte des lebens und der kulturen
geführt hat der klimawandel aus sicht
der afg also eher positive folgen wir
sagen als afd dass es den klimawandel
also wärme und kälteperioden immer schon
gegeben hat und dass es überhaupt keinen
grund gibt in deutschland unseren
industriellen kern zu schleifen wir
wandeln ja nicht unsere industrie um
sondern sie machen unsere industrie
kaputt und da sie jetzt auch gerade den
stahlmarkt erwähnt haben ich war heute
in einer gießerei in sachsen und ich
weiß nicht ob sie eine vorstellung haben
wie es dieser industrie in deutschland
geht sie machen mit ihrer politik diese
leute diese gießereien diese industrie
kaputt sie schalten kohlekraftwerke die
modernsten stehen im übrigen in
deutschland schalten sie ab sie schalten
die
kernkraftwerke ab sie gehen ein
sonderweg der überhaupt nicht nachhaltig
ist und noch einmal ich habe das immer
wiederholt sie verbauen den weg für
forschung und entwicklungsleistungen
hier wird die atomkraft als
brandgefährliche dinosaurier technologie
dargestellt aber wie verpassen den
anschluss an die neuen generation ich
hab das eben schon ausgeführt ein
thorium reaktor wir gerade in china
gebaut wird
lassen sie mich aus führen die aber die
waage lions wort vielleicht ist das
schon aufgefallen ich möchte gerne
ausführen was ein thorium reaktor kann
es kommt nicht das ist aber nicht das
thema diese sind entschuldigung
entschuldigung herkules ist aber genau
der punkt wir reden hier immer um den
heißen brei herum wir schleifen den
industriellen werken nachfragen nicht
jede stadt ihren das ist kaffee mappus
ich habe ich habe gesagt ja den
klimawandel hat es immer schon gegeben
und es gibt überhaupt keinen grund
unseren industriellen kern st das wäre
die antwort
forschung entwicklung und die nähte ist
bei ihrer forderung mit dem team noch
ambitionierter als filmten in ordnung zu
werden sie haben ihre antwort gegeben
vielen tagen also das ist natürlich auch
spricht für sich selbst frau r wissler
die linke ist bei ihren forderungen zum
klimaschutz noch ambitionierter als die
grünen sie wollen nämlich schon 20 30
mindestens 80 prozent weniger co2 als
1990 wie soll denn das gehen zumal sie
ja auch mit recht sagen es muss
unbedingt sozialverträglich sein ja
unbedingt und wir haben uns natürlich
angeschaut wie können wir die pariser
klimaschutzziele eingehalten und dass es
wie dringlich ist haben wir gerade
diesen sommer gesehen durch die
waldbrände durch die überschwemmungen
und deswegen müssen wir dringend handeln
wir brauchen und zum einen müssen wir
dringend die verkehrswende angehen wir
brauchen wir müssen deutschland zum
brand machen wirklich strecken
reaktivieren die stillgelegt wurden in
den letzten jahren bahnhöfe wieder
reaktivieren damit menschen eine
alternative zum auto haben wir könnten
zum beispiel sofort da sind wir drei uns
ja einig das tempolimit durchsetzen auf
autobahn wäre auf einen schlag zwei
millionen tonnen co2 die man auf einen
schlag ohne irgendwelche kosten
einsparen könnte der zweite punkt ist
dass die leute den klimawandel das ist
seit ihnen zu diskutieren da habe ich
aus einer lehrstelle sind freunde wir
müssen raus aus der kohle und zwar vor
2038 wir wollen raus aus der kohle jetzt
beginnen und bis 20.30 wir müssen sofort
aufhören wälder abzuholzen für
autobahnprojekte für flughafen projekte
weil melder die richter habe das wäre
die technologie soll das sozial
abgefedert werden wir brauchen eine wir
brauchen eine soziale abfederung was
bedeutet dass wir nicht die menschen die
sowieso schon wenig haben am stärksten
belasten dürfen und deswegen halten wir
es für notwendig dass wir zum beispiel
bei den fahrpreisen im öpnv ansetzen
also da die deutlich günstiger zu machen
damit menschen auch die möglichkeit also
nicht das autofahren grund erst mal
teurer sondern die pnv billiger damit
die menschen auch wirklich umsteigen
können und wir brauchen alternativen und
natürlich müssen wir die arbeitsplätze
in der industrie schützen deswegen
schlagen wir einen
transformationsprozess
weiterbildung umrüstung der industrie
weil wir deutschland ist ein industrie
dennoch soll es auch bleiben das
brauchen wir gerade wenn wir die
energiewende durchsetzen wollen die
verkehrswende dann brauchen industrie
dass ich ganz so wie
der landwirtschaft brauchen wir
natürlich auch eine wende also abkehr
von der massentierhaltung wir würden
gerne noch
in die zukunft schauen nämlich in die
zukunft der regierungs möglichkeiten für
viele wähler dürfte sie aber der
stimmabgabe auch wichtig sein welche
koalition sich am ende bilden dürften
verwaltet sie können sich jetzt im
moment entspannen weil moment ja keine
andere partei mit der aktif koalieren
möchte
also oder warum beschneiden sie die
möglichkeiten der union 1976 wurde auch
von platz zwei eine regierung gebildet
wir haben ein ganz klares ziel dass
armin laschet kanzler wird und der
überzeugendste regierungsauftrag begibt
sich mit einem klaren platz nummer eins
und wenn ich die demoskopie der letzten
tage so sie gehe ich eher letzter davon
aus dass dieses noch möglich ist möglich
ist die spd abzufangen märkte auch durch
solchen duellen die hier stattfinden
oder wie man das jetzt ein ende merkt
man welche richtung es geht auch wie
gemeinsam argumentiert wird wie ich
glaube dass ein linksbündnis das gewollt
ist und ein linksbündnis des mögliches
am ende unserem land schweren schaden
zufügen wird und das muss man wissen und
eine bürgerliche regierung am ende des
bestes was die zukunft und zwar sowohl
die erneuerung als auch die stabilität
gewährleistet und ich gehe davon aus
dass wir die nummer eins werden davon
bin ich fest überzeugt bei aus den
bändern auf platz eins ist muss man
nicht über platz zwei werden ganz
einfach er herr laschet erspare ich ihn
nicht also sie werden jetzt auch sagen
natürlich gehen sie davon aus dass sie
auf platz eins kommen theoretisch
konjunktiv für den fall sie camp die
union käme auf platz zwei würden sie
dann trotzdem versuchen eine regierung
zu bilden und sondieren also wir stehen
ja er fordert frage wenn die spd auf
platz zwei kommt ob sie wie schon
angedeutet trotzdem ein rot-rot-grünes
bündnis spd fragen stellen ist ja die
relevante frage über die die wähler
jetzt entscheiden müssen wird die union
so stark dass exakt diese koalition
nicht möglich wird wir haben heute vom
stellvertretend spd-parteivorsitzenden
gelesen dass er einen
mitgliederentscheid machen will über die
koalition eher stolz was ja
hassel wir wollen regieren dieses land
und die entscheidung die die wählerinnen
und wähler am kommenden sonntag fällen
müssen ist nicht wer wie aus 1 oder 2
was macht sondern ob wir in eine lage
rutschen dass ein solches bündnis
möglich wird dieser stellvertretende
parteivorsitzende namens kümmert hat
gesagt wenn man ein mitgliederentscheid
herr lindner sei ein luftikus die fdp
habe er dann noch in anderen dingen
beschriebene der minister erkennbar
worum es geht dass spd grüne und linke
eine mehrheit bilden wollen und wir tun
alles dass es dazu nicht aber wenn es
noch ein knappes ergebnis wir sind nicht
beim wenn wir sind drei tage vor der
wahl und ich würde vorschlagen
scholz sie waren ja schon mehrfach
angesprochen herr scholz also wir
bleiben ja dabei das war das was jetzt
also wenn sie auf die eins kommen
sondieren sie sowieso aber wir waren ja
jetzt bei der frage was wäre denn wenn
die spd auf den zweiten platz landen
sollte würden sie denn dann gleichzeitig
mit grünen und fdp oder mit grünen und
den linken koalieren oder in welcher
reihenfolge greifen sie da zuhörer und
guten ihre künftigen partner an ich
glaube das ist doch in der tat die
situation die auch meine beiden
vorredner schon beschrieben haben die
bürgerinnen bürger entscheiden wer der
nächste kanzler wird das tun sie auch
dadurch dass ihre stimme abgeben und ich
setze mich dafür ein dass das was die
umfragen jetzt
als möglich erkennen lassen auch
tatsächlich passiert nämlich dass es ein
sehr sehr starkes votum für die spd gibt
und dass sich daraus den auftrag
ableiten kann eine regierung zu führen
und für mich gibt es dabei eine ganze
reihe von rahmenbedingungen zu denen
zählt insbesondere das mit den
grundfunktionen unseres staates nicht
gespielt wird ich sag das mal sehr klar
wir brauchen einen verfassungsschutz den
wir auch in deutschland weiter stärken
müssen wir brauchen die zusammenarbeit
in der nato wir brauchen ein gutes
verhältnis zu den vereinigten staaten
von amerika lässt wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass wir ordentlich mit dem geld
umgehen und dass die wirtschaft wächst
dass die sicherheit im innern
funktioniert und wir eine starke
souveräne europäische union haben wir
müssen auch dafür sorgen dass die
bundeswehr sowie in den letzten jahren
weiter ausreichend ausgestattet wird all
das gehört zu den dingen die zum
regieren in deutschland dazu gehören
dann fragen wir doch gleich frau vista
die gerade indirekt angesprochen wurde
ist das alles für sie unterschreibt
wir kämpfen jetzt dafür die linke
gestärkt sondern es gibt ja genug punkte
die uns auch von der spd unterscheiden
und es gibt ja gute gründe warum es uns
als partei gibt warum wir zum beispiel
kritisieren dass jetzt gerade der
mindestlohn um zehn cent nur erhöht
wurde und hartz4 um drei euro was er
eine kürzung als eine erhöhung ist und
mit dem respekt da versprochen ist nicht
so viel zu tun hat aber ich sag mal so
wenn herr scholz eine seriöse
finanzpolitik bilder bin ich sehr
gespannt wie er sie mit herrn lindner
der 90 milliarden steuerentlastung
vorschlägt und gleichzeitig die steuer
die schuldenbremse einhalten will wie
sie das mit herrn
lindner durchsetzen wollen oder die
frage gesetzlicher mindestlohn erhöhen
wo aus der kohle das sind punkte da
haben wir übereinstimmung wir haben auch
eine ganze menge differenzen aber ich
bin der meinung wir müssen schluss
machen mit der politik der verlorenen
zeit es gibt eine ganze menge menschen
in diesem land die am abend vor der
altersarmut die können sie ihre wohnung
nicht mehr leisten wir müssen beim
klimaschutz vorankommen deswegen bin ich
der meinung dass wenn die drei parteien
nach der wahl eine rechnerische mehrheit
haben dass es dann dringend notwendig es
und alle drei in der verantwortung sind
darüber zu reden wie man zu einem
politikwechsel kommen damit man dieses
land eben zukunftssicher macht die
renten sichert und dafür sorgt dass die
soziale spaltung in diesem land nicht
immer weiter auseinandergeht darüber
würde ich gerne reden jetzt kämpfen wir
für eine starke linke weil wir natürlich
eine ganze menge position haben wir uns
auch sehr stark unterscheiden frau
bewirbt machen sie damit und reden sie
mit beiden seiten
demokratinnen und demokraten sollten
immer miteinander reden und das ist
unsere verantwortung jetzt und das
schöne ist wir leben in einem freien
land wir leben in einer demokratie wo
menschen frei entscheiden können wo
menschen vor gut 30 jahren in
ostdeutschland auf die straße gegangen
sind und gesagt haben so jetzt ist der
moment wo wir neuen mut aufbringen um
auch in freiheit in rechtsstaatlichkeit
und demokratie zu leben und genau da
stehen wir jetzt bei dieser bundestag
fehlt aber wo sie am meisten herausholen
können wagen wir einen echten neuen auf
hoch cdu und spd stehen für weiter so
wir als grüne sagen jetzt ist die zeit
ein neues kapitel aufzuschlagen
beim klimaschutz und ja ich bin zutiefst
davon überzeugt wir können deutschland
modernisieren wir können klimagerechten
wohlstand schaffen und das machen wir
mit den parteien mit denen es am besten
gelingt und glas auch ohne die starke
grüne führung ist es die klima ohne
schutz das funktioniert am ende nicht
aber am ende funktioniert auch keine
regierung stand jetzt ohne die fdp
deshalb noch zu ihnen herr lindner
im moment wie weit dürfte egal wir um
das rennen jetzt ausgeht der
zweitplatzierte denn zurückliegen damit
sie mit ihm verhandeln und sortieren
oder sondieren sie offen beide varianten
ampel und jamaika wir sind in einer ganz
neuen phase frau hassel mit an
sicherheit grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit
wird die stärkste partei
2021 dennoch von über 70 prozent der
deutschen nicht gewählt worden sein
daraus leitet sich scholz also eben kein
klarer regierungsbildungsauftrag ab es
geht dann um gespräche danach und wir
wollen möglichst stark werden unser ziel
ist zweistellig zu werden möglichst nah
an bündnis 90/die grünen herankommen
weil wir dann eben einfluss haben auf
die koalitions formate und die inhalte
ich sage ganz offen weil cdu und csu
ihre innere mitte ja offensichtlich
nicht gefunden haben traue ich ihnen
nicht zu anliegen der grünen zu
begrenzen und auf der anderen seite hat
armin laschet ja bereits hingewiesen auf
herrn kühnert auch herr trittin taucht
wieder öffentlich auf fresken schaltet
sich in die debatten ein da sieht man
dass herr scholz gehören auch richtig
dass herr scholz ein bürgerliches
auftreten hat die anderen sind aber noch
etwas begrenzt und deshalb deshalb die
erfolgen durch sagen wäre die fdp tritt
ein in einer koalition der mitte grüne
schulden rote steuererhöhungen hat sie
wollen es nicht schnelle schlussfrage an
alle und mittel mit der betonung schnell
welche regierung soll uns regieren
welche koalition arbeite natürlich eine
mit fdp-beteiligung
die inhaltlichen schnittmengen sind bei
jamaika am größten
union an nummer eins soll führen und
jamaica b eine option aber für uns kommt
einfach hin zu max mentoren dass die
bürgerliche regierung von unserem von
männern geführt wird schon alles für
eine cdu csu geführte regierung in
welches koalition ja eins ist jedenfalls
bei uns klipp und klar weder die linke
noch die afd
eine klima regierung
können sie etwas präziser
die gibt es nur mit starken grünen das
hat diese runde jahr deutlich gezeigt
sieben jahre weiter kohle verstromen
wird deutschland nicht in
klimaneutralität und damit auch nicht in
wohlstand der zukunft führen und
gefährde die freiheit unserer kinder und
enkelkinder und welche das will ich
verhindern deswegen braucht eine grün
geführte regierung die endlich ein neues
kapitel aufstieg für den wohlstand in
unserem land klimaneutral nochmal
konstellation welche koalition das
werden wir am ende sehen ob es für ein
zweierbündnis reich für ein
dreierbündnis reicht aber ohne grüne an
der führung ist es wie klimaschutz das
klappt nicht also keine antwort der
stelle herr scholz ganz auftraten ich
möchte die bürgerinnen bürger bitten
dass sie ihre entscheidung die sie
erwogen haben den letzten tagen und
wochen dass sie eine regierung wollen
die von mir geführt werden könnte auch
möglich machen indem sie ein starkes
votum für die spd abgeben die
zweitstimme ist die kanzler stimme und
wer will dass sich der nächste
regierungschef werde der sollte auch die
spd wählen wir werden dann die
möglichkeit nutzen vielleicht reizt ist
ja auch zu zweit das ist ja auch eine
möglichkeit die passieren kann und
deshalb geht es vor allem um ein sehr
starkes votum weil zurzeit haben sie nur
eine dame angeschaut frau wissler bei
uns ist ganz klar herr lasche wir werden
sie nicht zum kanzler wählen und herr
lindner wenig zugang hat finanzminister
programmatisch haben wir die größten
übereinstimmungen mit spd und grünen das
ist klar und dann muss man eben nach der
wahl schauen wenn ich mir die
wahlkampagne so anschaue sehe ich da
viele übereinstimmungen muss man nach
der wahl schauen ob es um reiche im
politiker ich sage danke denn das war es
schon wieder mit unserer schlussrunde
die geht zu ende in drei tagen wissen
wir dann mehr zumindest wer und in
welcher konstellation eine chance hat
seine heute geäußerten vorstellungen
auch umsetzen zu können in der nachfolge
von an merkel nach 16 jahren beginnt
dann nämlich eine neue ära und manchmal
wenn eine lange ära endet dauert es
länger als gedacht bis das neue in allen
kulturen zu erkennen ist ihnen noch
einen guten und entspannten abend
[Musik]